en 2006 c'est le diagnostic tombe emilie
est atteinte de sclérose en plaques une
maladie auto immune qui impacte le
système nerveux central l'avenir
professionnel est alors un certain pour
la jeune femme j'ai apprise j'étais en
fin de fin d'études donc là c'est un peu
le choc et on se voit tout de suite
puisque sg a longtemps
oui on se voit tout de suite bon
fauteuil roulant quand ledit sclérose en
plaques c'est toute ma famille tout le
monde pensait que c'était fauteuil
roulant dans quelques années et donc
c'est un peu compliqué de se dire qu'est
ce que j'ai bien pouvoir faire
aujourd'hui emilie à 38 ans elle est
déclarée travailleuse handicapée un
handicap invisible qui lui a valu des
remarques désagréables au sein de son
environnement professionnel
les personnes sont pas censés savoir non
plus la maladie c'est pas écrit sur la
tête et voilà mais des personnes qui
vous disent bien reprends toi va faire
une sieste et arrêtent et puis bah le ce
que j'ai eus sympathique ça arrête de
faire la fête arrête de boire quand tu
quand tu vis au travail sachant qu'avec
les scléroses en plaques il faut encore
des petites pertes d'équilibré donc
j'aimerais lui dire bah si seulement
mais n'en faites juste fatigué mais
voilà mais c'est un final c'est
tellement rare par rapport à l'évolution
que j'ai pu avoir et aux personnes que
j'ai pu rencontrer mais quand ça arrive
ça
ça pique un peu salariés d'une filiale
de distribution d'électricité depuis
2008 fatigue arrêt maladie ou encore
rendez vous à l'hôpital tous les 6 mois
rythme sa carrière face à ces
contraintes des mesures ont été prises
pour aménager son poste j'en absence
pour renouveler nos documents
l'aménagement du temps de travail
l'aménagement du poste donc l'appareil
dans un ergot dans le siège dont le pc
pour le clavier pour la souris sera donc
vraiment ils sont vraiment très très
très très au fait très très impliqué de
par son témoignage elle espère faire
changer le regard porté sur le handicap
visible et invisible en entreprise